like a maintenance it wasn't I'm here it
was tomato nightmare this is so much
London yeah we gotta do this again yes
please
should we get someone on the books I
mean we're here sure yeah
do it who I've just been so busy I'm so
busy
tired busy and tired like my mantra I
swear I'm the busiest person I know and
believe me I'm busier what are you doing
on Wednesday I gotta think you available
Thursday afternoon
busy mmm Friday I got work than yoga and
drinks without son of a [ __ ] you just
reminded me I got work yoga and drinks
with a friend you available in the
following three weekends
yeah booked booked and boom same
September you know like I'm gonna be
tired bad luck yeah
November 14th is Thanksgiving sorry bud
Washington's birthday I would love to
but I'm having a Washington's birthday
party the 24 charity event Hanukkah oh
Hanukkah
I'm very comic yeah me too I'm
celebrating Hanukkah the first day of
spring I'll be at the dentist the next
Tuesday
I have drinks with my dentist oh my more
you'll say no your no can do
oh I'll figure this out yeah well
figures happy
2,023 no there has to be some day in the
foreseeable future where both of us are
free I never wanted to be this person
the busy guy mister I'm tired funny
thing is I don't really know what makes
me so busy I mean I don't even have a
job
maybe we're not that busy with that
tired
maybe we just don't want to do anything
because would lease banality
is always time for a friend what's the
point of living if you can't share your
experiences of someone you care about
yeah I mean I'm really busy man I am
really busy too so I guess this is it
I'm never gonna see each other again
wait a second are you doing tonight I'm
gonna be sleeping coz I'm tired
exactly hey I'm really glad that we were
busy
oh my god I totally forgot about